Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
Are you unsure today?
No!
Not like it's our FUWAMOCO birthday today, right?
BAU BAU!
And today, it's our birthday!
And we're your host of FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you for joining us today for our 76th episode of FUWAMOCO Morning and on our birthday!
BAU BAU!
To be exact, Moco-chan, your birthday, right?
My birthday.
Your birthday.
Happy birthday, Moco-chan.
Thank you!
It's an extra special episode of FUWAMOCO Morning today.
But, Ruffians!
There might be a couple of Ruffians who've stumbled in today, you know what I mean?
Oh, it's a little bit of a extra special FUWAMOCO Morning.
Wow.
It's not every day, it's our birthday.
BAU!
It's just once a year.
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
FWMC Morning!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
You don't need to celebrate the hashtag, hashtag.
It's not what you're supposed to be celebrating today.
No!
What are they supposed to be celebrating, huh, Moco-chan?
Why are all these streamers and the balloons and presents?
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
It's an extra, extra special day today.
I wonder what it could be hard.
Just a thought.
Isn't it so wonderful to get to wake up and spend a birthday morning together with the Ruffians?
BAU BAU.
No words can get better than BAU.
Wow.
Well... It's about to get worse, Ruffians.
Because... There's been... Another Pero Sighting.
On our birthday... We already had Pero leave us that nasty birthday message, right?
What now?
Well...
Let's see what the Ruffians saw, huh?
What's this?
A birthday party for... Pero?
You did all this for him?
That's nice that you prepared this wonderful birthday party for him.
All for him!
Fine.
All the pink decorations!
And you know it!
It being my birthday today too!
No, I definitely didn't think that maybe this was prepared for my birthday.
It's all for Pero's birthday, huh?
Now...
Pero's deciding to take over my birthday too.
No, I already had to share it with Fuwawa.
And now finally when I get to celebrate my birthday, just my own birthday this year, with the Ruffians now.
No.
Pero is truly nasty.
Don't worry, Moco-chan.
It'll be a wonderful birthday for you today.
It's really nice that you decided to organize this big birthday party all for Pero.
I guess it's a nice effort.
Right?
Look at Pero!
Do you see?
I guess he's so happy.
I should be happy for him.
Just don't forget that it's my birthday too, okay?
What is Pero's birthday?
He's too nasty.
He doesn't get a birthday.
Well, then... I guess I'm happy for him.
If he doesn't get a birthday ever, then... I guess I'm happy.
Let's all make sure that we celebrate Moco-chan's birthday today.
And, uh... Well, Pero, you know...
Maybe he can come a little later.
Right?
Maybe.
BAU BAU!
He does look really happy though.
Right?
You can just feel the happiness radiating from his lumpy body.
I just... BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
I want to say thank you so much for celebrating my birthday yesterday!
Yesterday, my 48 hours FUWAMOCO birthday officially started.
As you know, we counted down the very first moments to it all together.
In the evening yesterday, it was my birthday party!
Yeah!
Your first birthday party!
First one ever!
You know, I love the barns and I sang my favorite songs for you.
Thank you Ruffians for having so much fun together with me!
I'll never ever forget it!
We also received some birthday messages and gifts from Advent.
I also got a really sweet letter from you, Moco-chan!
What was it that you called me, Moco-chan?
Nothing!
I was so happy!
Thank you, Ruffians, for making me the happiest and fluffiest demon dog in the world!
BAU BAU!
But!
Today!
Today is Moco-chan's birthday!
Your big day!
Happy birthday, Moco-chan.
BAU BAU!
The birthday celebration never would stop.
Make sure you don't forget about my birthday too, okay?
The 48-hour FUWAMOCO Birthday continues, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
I can't believe it, you know.
We get to have such a special FUWAMOCO Morning.
A birthday FUWAMOCO Morning.
Why?
You know, Mama Puppy would always celebrate our birthday morning very specially, BAU.
Well, this is just about right up there, huh?
BAU BAU!
Wow, Ruffians!
Not only was it my birthday, but I also had a little surprise for you.
I announced my first birthday merch!
BAU BAU!
I feel so excited and happy to be able to share this with you, Ruffians!
Do you see?
My birthday merch has such a beautiful illustration by Miwami Sakura-sensei!
You know?
And, well, you can see it right here, nice and big.
Do you want to take a closer look?
But, while here's my birthday mindset, if you really want to be able to enjoy the illustration even more, well, I have a dual-lid acrylic pa- acrylic!
What did you say?
Acrylic paddle!
As well as also a bonus postcard with my signature printed in gold on it.
Right.
It's not very often that you get to see my signature, huh, Ruffians?
But!
Hi!
I think, you know, this is maybe what I'm looking for the very, very most, I'm most excited for this!
The Ruffian!
Ruffian!
BAU BAU!
Look at him!
He's so cute!
With the little glasses there!
Little legs!
Ruffians!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
BAU BAU!
You know, I hope that you'll decide to give lots of hugs, lots of head pats, too.
I'm definitely looking forward to it, too.
BAU BAU!
And we have my Fuwawa motif t-shirt!
Now, you might think, oh, it's just a white t-shirt.
It is not!
Don't you dare!
Look, it has my little flames just like on my cool jacket here.
And our Advent branding label there.
And on the background, we have some very cute Fuwawa pondering.
With my name right there.
You know it's nice because, well, it's not like...
If you had my face big and printed on it, maybe it might be hard to like, where if you're gonna go, maybe see your parents, you know?
But this way, you can still be like, yes!
Yeah!
Way to work, okay!
It's very work appropriate.
You know they have the, what's the word?
The Fridays.
You know the casual Fridays?
Casual Fridays!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
But not just that, we also have my FUWAMOCO keychain!
Look, my fluffy tail's there!
But, well, unlike the actual thing, this time it's made out of rubber.
My tail is not rubber.
It's not that fluffy, huh?
In reality, it's very fluffy.
But we also have an acrylic pattern with my name there!
That way you know you can-
Bless you.
Happy birthday bless you.
Birthday sneeze!
But this way there's no way you can get confused and think, oh this is Moco-chan's tail.
No, it's mine.
Exactly!
BAU BAU!
And well, we also have an extra special birthday voice part.
Special situation boys and all.
You know how FUWAMOCO really like going on walks?
Well, I wanted to go on a little bit of a forest adventure with you.
So, I hope that you'll listen to it.
It's recorded in Japanese and English.
So, please listen to it and maybe you can see, oh, a lot of different sides of Fuwawa, too.
BAU BAU!
And we have the complete set.
If you purchase it, you get a little bit of a bonus.
It comes with a
Appreciation voice also in Japanese and English.
You know, because I really, really want to be able to say a big thank you to you.
And well, I know there was a limited edition set.
Thank you, Ruffians, so much for getting your paws on them.
I think it sold out in a few seconds.
Very, very fast.
Very fast.
But the limited edition, it came with my very own handwritten autograph.
But don't worry about that.
Cause there's also the complete set and like I mentioned there's a postcard with Miwabe Sakura-sensei's illustration on it and also with my signature printed gold on it too. So I really hope that you'll pick up the complete set because there's so many exciting goodies in it, you know, and well...
I just feel so lucky and so happy to be able to have this opportunity to be able to release merch as a member of hololive.
I really hope that Ruffians are as excited as me and that you'll check them out, okay?
Everything which will only be on sale until the beginning of March.
So don't miss out, okay Ruffians?
Not that long of a window, huh?
Oh, wait.
I'm also Ruffians.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Nothing funny, nothing silly.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Now you know it's just the exciting part until we can get our paws on them.
BAU BAU!
Well, the excitement doesn't end.
It does not end!
This week it's been a bit of a rollercoaster that's just going up, up, up, up!
You know, it happens six more times a week.
That makes it sound like it's gonna go down.
Uh, when it goes down... No!
But when the rollercoaster goes down, that's when generally the fun happens, right?
It's just going up.
But it's been, Advent 6 month anniversary and now our birthday too!
But you know, there's also been something very exciting coming around the corner too.
A certain pink and
Red holiday perhaps?
Yeah!
Valentine's Day!
BAU BAU!
And to celebrate it, hololive has released a collection of Valentine's voice packs for 2024!
And while at FUWAMOCO, we're participating in it along with Advent too!
Look, Shiori!
Of course the Watame-senpai.
I don't want to lose out to Watame-senpai's fluffiness.
But, well, Ruffians, you know, doing this voice pack, it was my first time doing something like this and we were really nervous.
Even with all the excitement that birthday's going on, we really hope that you'll check them out, listen to them, and maybe accept our feelings too.
I know.
It was... embarrassing, but...
I did my best, okay?
I know!
We have Japanese and English versions!
Please definitely look... Look at them!
Listen to them!
Look at them with your ears open!
Look at them with your ears, okay?
Did we write the scripts?
Well... I know!
There's a lot of birthday excitement too right now.
I think we'd really like to be able to hear your response to our Valentine voices too!
But!
They'll be available until the beginning of April.
So don't worry, okay?
We'll make sure you don't miss it!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, I love you!
Don't forget though.
It's my birthday.
It is my birthday.
Valentine still has to wake up.
Wait a few weeks.
It dies, okay?
So, Mococo's birthday!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
It seems like we've received an important FUWAMOCO scoop from our Ruffians!
Thank you so much, Soyoneko, for the impeccable journalism!
BAU BAU!
Wow, like I mentioned, you know, this week wasn't just filled with special milestones and anniversaries, but we also had some amazing new outfits from our DP-senpai!
Look!
La+-senpai revealed her first new outfit!
An outfit that she designed herself!
You know it!
Very very cool!
Very fitting!
And you know the fire design even moves around!
Crazy.
Well, I don't know.
She looks a little grown up now.
Does she?
Oh, uh, wait.
Maybe Mofu is- Is that a bit rude to say to a senpai?
Alright!
And you can see her tummy now, too.
Just a bit.
Don't get tummy empty, okay, Moco-chan?
Also, Okayu-senpai showed off her special new trial model that she'll be using during her ASMR membership stream!
It's so cute!
And you know, I, I, I, feel, feel the ears if she's feeling a little bit warm.
She can, uh, zip down the jacket too.
So, uh, zip reveals some, uh, cute, uh,
Under pajamas!
Pajamas!
Under pajamas.
Oh my gosh.
BAU BAU!
Wow, they're both super cute!
Congratulations on the new outfit!
A new model of Senpai!
Okayu Senpai!
BAU BAU!
Pajamas!
Sometimes I feel a bit warm too, but... BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, you know, with it being our birthday and everything, obviously Mama Puppy and Papa Puppy have been really excited and wish us a big happy birthday too!
Actually, Mama Puppy came by quickly with some handmade cakes just like she used to make us!
BAU BAU!
What do you think, Ruffians?
They're super cute, right?
You know what?
Mama Puppy was actually sulking a little bit because she said that they didn't turn out as well as she'd hoped.
They look great, right?
You know, they sort of look like cupcakes, but they're actually around the size of two cupcakes.
Right!
Yeah, so we shared my cake together yesterday, and we'll be sharing Moco-chan's cake together later today, right?
Yeah!
It was really delicious, though!
The frosting, it wasn't too sweet, and the cake, it was light and fluffy!
Because, you know, it's my FUWAMOCAKE!
I hope that, you know, mine's not fuzzy on the inside.
We'll have to see.
We feel really really lucky to have such a loving Mama Puppy and papa puppy on top of having you here by our side, Ruffians!
We're the luckiest puppies ever, huh, Moco-chan?
BAU BAU!
Next we have for you, the Doggie of the Day!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
Aria!
Can you believe it, Ruffians?
It's Aria's birthday today too!
Moco-chan has the same birthday.
Happy birthday, Oryo!
Happy birthday!
Congrats on your sixth birthday!
You're just a puppy that's high.
High.
I guess, yeah.
But, you know, she loves napping, so hopefully she won't sleep through it.
I know.
Definitely not.
How does Oryo BAU BAU?
Oh, it's birthday rice on me.
BAU BAU BAU!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
BAU BAU
Oryo's special day!
Oryo's birthday!
And you know, she's been with you for so many birthdays.
But she's still a puppy.
Yeah, there'll be many more birthdays, many more wonderful memories together.
And I think I can tell she's looking forward to lots more tweets.
That's what the face says, huh?
Yeah, especially those birthday tweets today.
And also even more cuddles from you two.
Hi!
BAU BAU!
And for today, I went on a walk.
We have De-den!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
This world really is hot.
BAU BAU!
I like how this guy is celebrating my birthday too hot!
Yeah, the moco clowns!
Amazing.
BAU BAU.
Next, for our Question of the Day, we have... De-den!
Hello, FUWAMOCO!
Hello!
I was wondering, was there a specific moment that made you want to join hololive yourselves?
Or was it something you wanted from the moment you figured out that Akai Hato was not, in fact, a visual novel heroine?
That's such a good question.
Wow.
Well, you know, Haachama-senpai, she helped introduce us into what hololive was, but what really made us want to be a part of the hololive family was just all our talented senpai from all over the world with so many different experiences, talents, and personalities.
You know, seeing their strength, growth, them working hard all together for their dreams.
It really resonated with us, you know?
You know, especially with us.
We're such hungry puppies too.
Plus, you know, we really, we haven't found our duty yet.
We haven't found really our place, so...
We're really, really happy to be here now.
And now we can protect your smiles!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions today.
Thank you for always being a part of FUWAMOCO Morning.
BAU BAU!
Don't forget!
Use the hashtag "hashtag FUWAMOCO Morning" and "hashtag FUWAMOCO Scoop" for your scoops!
BAU BAU!
And for our next stream, what could it be, what could it be, what could it be?
It couldn't be a big party or anything, right?
Today, it's Moco-chan's birthday!
You haven't forgotten, right, Ruffians?
Now, we didn't mention it a bazillion times, huh?
It's my birthday party today!
So you know, I'm gonna have a solo karaoke concert as well!
We're gonna have lots of fun together, cuz that's what I want!
Okay.
You're very ready!
Thank you!
Let's all chill out!
I'm not nervous.
I'm not nervous!
I also need you to be there to hold my paw a little bit.
We'll be cheering really loud for you, Moco-chan.
BAU BAUing from the audience, okay?
Me and the Ruffians.
BAU BAUing!
Moco-chan, BAU BAUing!
That's what you're gonna do from the audience.
Yeah, I'm getting all prepared.
Practiced.
BAU BAU!
Let me take a quick peek at our schedule!
Well, after all our birthday excitement, after Moco-chan's birthday is over,
You know, we clean up the decorations and we finally say goodbye to our FUWAMOCO birthday.
48 hours!
We'll be continuing our saga in Metal Gear Solid 2!
But this time, can we actually save the president?
You know, the people may be like, save the president!
Oh wait, no, first this.
Right.
We'll see!
We'll see.
BAU BAU!
Hi.
Happy birthday, happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today on this very special birthday FUWAMOCO Morning!
But before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Rubenon!
BAU BAU!
It's time!
DJ Culp.
BAU BAU!
Morachi.
Boyz Benz.
BAU BAU!
Portal.
Morachi.
BAU BAU!
Oh, Double Access Special?
Tamumi no Tamako.
BAU BAU!
Dio Bando.
Come!
BAU BAU!
Save!
Bambi!
BAU BAU!
Roran!
Sayori!
BAU BAU!
Ice Fibers!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!
My birthday party!